the co-host on the talk went full pop
star and you know what i dressed up as
well as myself
yeah okay for this wild e.t exclusive
it's harry styles i guess i'm on a
watermelon sugar high
watermelon sugar you like this right
well rockstar right today was arm day
it's live entertainment tonight we're
entertaining tonight
[Music]
i like that she's empowered with her
sexuality yes but i also love that she
plays an instrument
will you keep this and wear it out on
halloween all i know is my husband would
love to see ariana
thank you
thank you
here's me
gaga
[Music]
her voice you know is sort of raspy and
deep and she doesn't really smile you
lock it
[Music]
what made you choose bruno mars 24 karat
no
[Music]
i know i'm like a whole foot and an inch
taller than him akbar's bruno suit
custom made amanda's glam gaga eyes that
was an hour and a half in makeup and
jerry's harry styles grammy look comes
complete with the feather boa yep the
newest talk hosts are channeling their
favorite pop stars and totally embracing
the show's 10-year halloween tradition
the ponytail is what it's all about and
the nails even i got in on the fun for
tomorrow's talktacular show you'll see
me playing myself on the orange carpet
cheryl the new team seems like it's set
we're really showing not just america
but the world of what it looks like to
have diverse conversations with men and
women i think this might be the crew
unless i get fired
[Applause]
[Music]